mostly it's simp guys talking and you're
so used to most women are so used to
having men cater to them and a lot of
simp guys around them speaking generally
yeah to you like a woman and so when you
say oh it's how you say it it's your
tone you're saying hey communicate to me
like a woman men do not talk like that
if I if I was to talk direct to a guy or
be very serious then you would say oh
she's mascul you're very masculine
you've been doing that all episod I
don't care I don't give a about say
you swear wow so can I correct this how
your Nigerian parents rais you can I
just correct are you insane let me
correct something a woman how they to be
a woman